el futuro político de donald trump está
en manos del senado la cámara de
representantes- en el juicio entregó
formalmente la acusación por escrito
contra el exmandatario a los senadores
el único cargo del que se acusa al ex
presidente es incitar a la insurrección
durante un discurso a sus seguidores el
pasado 6 de enero antes de que cientos
de ellos asaltaron el capitolio marco
one artículo primero incitación a la
insurrección la constitución dispone que
la cámara de representantes tendrá el
poder exclusivo de acusación y el
presidente será destituido de su cargo
en caso de acusación y condena por
traición soborno u otros delitos graves
y faltas además la sección 3 de la
decimocuarta enmienda de la constitución
prohíbe a cualquier persona que abro
comillas participó en una insurrección o
rebelión contra estados unidos de ocupar
cualquier cargo en eeuu cierro comillas
android y night state and work en
entrevista con la cadena de noticias cnn
el presidente joe biden aseguró que no
cree que haya suficientes votos en el
senado para condenar a la expresión
/ trump en este su segundo juicio
político muchos aseguran que será muy
difícil lograr que 17 senadores
republicanos voten para condenar al
magnate el número necesario de votos y
los 50 demócratas votan por una condena
trump es el único presidente de eeuu que
ha sido acusado dos veces por la cámara
de representantes y se convertirá en el
primero en enfrentar un juicio después
de dejar el cargo se espera que el
senado inicia el juicio el próximo 9 de
febrero en base al artículo presentado
este lunes